[Música]
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden pronunció su segundo discurso
sobre el estado de La Unión El
mandatario se pronunció sobre el límite
de la deuda el gasto social la guerra
rusa en Ucrania y las polémicas con
china una antesala de sus planes de
anunciar su campaña de reelección en las
próximas semanas nos acompaña para
hablar sobre este tema Munich en
analista política y social de entonces
global advisory desde Washington DC
Muchísimas gracias a usted y vimos un
discurso que estuvo muy centrado en
política interna destacando
principalmente los logros en materia
económica y siendo la economía la
principal preocupación de los
estadounidenses le pregunto si puede
leerse en este enfoque la intención
reeleccionista de biden yo creo que este
fue el el primer discurso de la campaña
de biden para la próxima presidencia y
él lo que hizo fue centrarse en celebrar
sus logros y en Buscar cooperación pero
lo con respecto a los logros lo que hay
es un una especie de disonancia porque
él sí ha generado pues muchísimos ha
cumplido muchísimas de sus promesas de
campaña ha tenido logros en la economía
en el empleo en el tema de salud de
Educación con respecto al covid como
mencionaban y y los los digamos los puso
de primeros en la en el discurso
Vimos a un biden fortalecido vital y con
muchas ganas de tratar de cerrar esa
brecha entre los logros que ha tenido
que estar en sustentados por números y
la percepción del público que es de un
presidente
débil en una en una comunidad
descontenta
sin embargo lo que vimos fue que también
hubo muy poco espacio para la política
exterior Muy apenas unas cuantas
menciones para Ucrania y para china Por
qué
sobre china el Pues digamos se presentó
fuerte y y con una con una retórica un
poco agresiva y
contundente pero la totalidad del
discurso fue como una especie de América
First del lado del lado demócrata Y eso
también es una seña de las de los
intereses de las prioridades de los
americanos en este momento él sin duda
ha leído los las encuestas y y ha visto
el descontento que hay con respecto a la
economía la inflación al empleo al tema
del
crimen y todos los temas sociales que en
este momento preocupan a a los
americanos de los dos partidos pero lo
que creo Es que sus asesores le
sugirieron que se enfocara en la
política doméstica que ya la política
internacional está muy centrada en los
dos temas que tocó pues principalmente
que fue China y Rusia y que a los
americanos de
del montón no les interesa ir más allá y
sin embargo me llama la atención que
durante toda esta semana y la anterior
hemos tenido como titular el supuesto
presunto globo espía chino pero sobre
eso apenas hubo una mención a qué podría
deberse esto Tal vez temores a más
críticas de la oposición o a empañar un
poco su discurso digamos
reeleccionista sin duda lo hizo muy
pocas o casi ninguna mención específica
al al globo que nos cautivó durante toda
la semana lo que sí hizo fue aprovechar
el discurso para dar una advertencia a
China y y se quedó ahí no entró en
detalles muy posiblemente porque pensaba
que te quería utilizar su tiempo para
pues para mostrar toda la los logros en
todos los temas que que son la
preocupación principal Así que fue pasó
por encima de esta semana y
descaradamente ahora con miras a su
campaña de reelección que esperamos
anuncien las próximas semanas quisiera
preguntarles si anoche fue un buen
escenario para reafirmar el apoyo del
partido Porque algunos demócratas les
preocupa la edad de baiden cumplió 80
años en noviembre comenzaría un nuevo
mandato en caso de ser reelegido a sus
82 años y pues además está está viéndose
que podría enfrentar unas candidaturas
republicanas muy fuertes por no ir más
lejos Donald Trump de santis
es verdad y la tiene difícil y yo creo
que por eso tenía tanto interés en
mostrarse vital y fuerte y listo para
para avanzar unos cuatro años más el
tema también Ángela Es que no hay muchos
contenedores del lado demócrata que
puedan ser unas alternativas a baiden
Así que no no creo que el partido tenga
una una banca nutrida como la tiene
quizás el partido republicano y y que su
mejor carta sin duda Va a ser por lo
menos en este momento del del calendario
electoral
mire volviendo al tema del discurso y
más que nada a la respuesta que
posteriormente dio la gobernadora de
Arkansas Sarah Ella habló de una nueva
generación de líderes republicanos donde
deja eso las intenciones de Trump por el
estado la espalda a quien fuera su jefe
en el gobierno pasado o a qué se refiere
con esta nueva generación republicana
existe una nueva generación de santis
podría ser parte de de esa de esa
generación lo creo que lo que lo dice lo
que dicen los números en este momento es
que Trump no es el candidato que será
ungido por su partido porque tiene unos
números bastante menos
populares de popularidad un poco más
bajos de lo que se esperaba y creo que
la presencia deslizantes le hace
bastante sombra pero no solo eso sino
que faltan dos años y hay una un equipo
de sí del senadores gobernadores y las
mismas
que están mirando hacia adelante hacia
un cambio de generación en el partido
ahora también hay un claro llamado de
cooperación con la oposición republicana
algo que muchas veces parece medio
utópico y sin embargo si hay esperanza
en que pueda haber iniciativas
bipartidistas la primera persona a la
que saludo biden fue el nuevo presidente
de la cámara que vil mccarthy y bueno
habló de las posibilidades de trabajo en
temas como el techo de la deuda que una
gran prioridad pendiente la reforma
policial de la que se habla todos los
años y también una reforma migratoria
los tres temas sin duda muy importantes
en la agenda legislativa
son temas Que muy posiblemente no logren
consenso lo que sí hizo biden puede ser
muy consistente con su con su obsesión
de trabajar de manera bipartidista lo
prometió en la campaña lo ha cumplido
Hasta cierto punto en algunas en la
legislación Pero antes de que cambiara
el el la mayoría de la cámara de
representantes Entonces él Sí sigue
invitando al a los a los políticos y
prometiéndole al público que una
solución bipartidista para todos esos
temas especialmente temas tan complejos
como la migración se deben
trabajar conjuntamente eso también le
pone un poco la la luz a los
republicanos y y le da la el permiso si
si se oponen a trabajar así los los
puede titular de optimistas y y pues
debilitar un poco su argumento pero sí
hubo muchísima oposición de la de la
derecha radical y pues gritos y pero en
general en su en sus números hay más
bipartidismo de lo que ha habido en los
últimos tiempos bien y ya nos estamos
quedando sin tiempo para finalizar eh
quisiera preguntarle por una comparación
el año pasado el discurso de vaiden
llegó pocos días después de la invasión
rusa de Ucrania y se centró en una gran
medida en explicar la respuesta de
Estados Unidos Cuál fue la diferencia
con el discurso de este año
en la guerra ya desafortunadamente está
cumpliendo un año como como bien lo
señalas y realmente la el mensaje fue
vamos a seguir por este camino no tener
no tiene vaiden la obligación en este
momento ya cuando hemos escuchado y
seguido de las noticias de la invasión
de de Rusia a Ucrania de explicar su
estrategia de seguridad nacional primero
porque ha sido apoyada por muchos países
de occidente y segundo porque parece
estar funcionando en el sentido de que
tienen en Ucrania Pues un receptor de
ayuda
muy valiente y muy consistente así que
en la medida en que él no haya tenido
unos grandes traspiés en esta en esta
política dejó las cosas de esa manera es
el digamos diciendo que que iba a
continuar en este esfuerzo internacional
de de proteger a Ucrania muni jensen
analista política invitada de France 24
gracias a usted por estar con nosotros
Muchas gracias